ce gant tracts pétitions un drôle de
comité d'accueil pour les clients de
l'hypermarché carrefour de beaune une
journée de grève pour alerter la
clientèle des risques du plan de
restructuration de leurs enseignes
je comprends les revendications des
personnes qui risquent de perdre leur
emploi surtout que c'est un service de
proximité pour beaune les alentours
donc je les soutiens tout cas mouvement
de grève pour l'heure pas de fermetures
prévues pour ce magasin mais caissier
magasinier au responsable de rayon
tiennent à tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
cet hypermarché déjà géré par une
filiale de carrefour mais dans ce
contexte de restructuration
ils craignent de sortir purement et
simplement du groupe et que leur outil
de travail soit placé en location
gérance pour les salariés la conséquence
est importante puisque derrière c'est la
perte de leurs droits de tous les droits
des deux acquis sociaux que nous avons
négocié depuis dix ans voilà c'est une
perte de rémunération qui est estimé à
20 % du brut annuel et c'est aussi
exquise important c'est l'obligation de
travailler le dimanche
avec un risque derrière bien sûr c'est
sur l'emploi ont dû réduire les
effectifs dans ses magasins à beaune si
certains salariés de carrefour craignent
pour leur statut d'autres devraient
perdre leur emploi
ce supermarché contact comme trois
autres de la région permettra d'ici 2022
ceux de châtillon-sur-seine et gueugnon
seront placés eux en location gérance au
niveau national ce plan de
restructuration doit entraîner la
suppression de 2100 emplois